a luta
pessoal a priori beleza anós seguinte é
sobre lugar
eu sou comediante palestrante professor
criatividade e hoje eu queria
compartilhar o idéia que é o que eu
considero ser a maior lacuna o maior
déficit ea maior oportunidade e todo o
universo da educação porque a rede houve
muito o povo dizer por aí que as escolas
têm que mudar né
aitor direto escola tem que mudar a
escola tem que mudar a escola tem que
mudar
eu já falei muito isso sempre que eu
ouço isso eu acho que a pessoa está
querendo dizer no fundo que a educação
precisa mudar porque a escola e educação
é diferente
a escola é uma das formas de educar
seres humanos
uma das formas é a maior iniciativa
coletiva da sociedade para educar é mas
não é a única e nem é a mais relevante
porque a variável mais relevante pai do
cáceres humanos é liderança familiar
velho toda criança tem uma liderança
normalmente o pai mãe mas de outras
configurações familiares hoje dia né ea
lhe era familiar é quem mais influencia
lembrando que lidera não é que procria
lida é que lidera tão pai que educa lida
é que lidera ea liderança é a variável
mais importante saber porquê porque a
forma mais eficiente de educação não é o
ensino é o exemplo e quem vive com a
criança é a família e viver é educar
porque viver é dá exemplos
muita gente não se liga marcada conversa
que você tem com a criança está educando
cada conversa que você não tem uma
criança está educando cada conversa que
você tem com outra pessoa que a criança
escutou você tá educando cada decisão
que você faz na sua vida
cada escolha que você toma cada reação
que você tem se a criança teve acesso
àquela cena ou educação
mesmo que ela não tenha entendido certo
e tocou foi papai
então a família é a variável mais
importante na educação então prédio
caixão mudar tem que mudar suas escolas
têm que mudar
a família também né é para que a escola
seja a segunda casa a casa tem que ser a
primeira escola
o bagulho funcionar bem porque precisa
mudar porque todo mundo fala em mudar
mudar mas porque tudo na vida tem que
começar com porque ele é o guarda parada
então vou dar uma explicação rápida e
por que essas coisas todas têm que mudar
a explicação é a seguinte ele a educação
é o processo de preparação de seres
humanos da humanidade educação isso só
que a necessidade de seres humanos para
humanidade está mudando porque está
mudando porque a população está
crescendo a diversidade está aumentando
a tolerância está diminuindo a ansiedade
está bombando a clareza mental está
assumindo a tecnologia está ficando
muito inteligente a hiperconectividade
tá deixando tudo muito junto e no meio
desse rolo tal planeta dando os avisos e
se liga e perde no ar é o texto velho e
débito não teve com o texto diz é
inédito e um contexto extremamente
complexo
queria abrir um parêntesis só para falar
dessa palavra que eu amo que a palavra
complexo complexo a palavra linda que
como vem junto plexo vez de tecido então
complexo é preciso junto que [ __ ] ter
sido junto o mundo tá complexo tá tudo
ter sido juntos esta paredes beleza
então a humanidade complexa está
necessitando de novos tipos de seres
humanos por isso que as iniciativas em
educação de seres humanos tem que mudar
porque a humanidade não precisa de mais
decorador de informação que a formação
está abundante não precisa de mais
repertório padrão porque os padrões
antigos não servem por um problema novo
ao mandado do samae de seguidores mas
nada porque a manada não sabe votar
ainda então a educação precisa mudar
esse é o meu povo
a educação precisa mudar agora tanto
como como queria falar sobre o processo
de mudança processo de mudança que serve
a qualquer mudança
todo processo de mudança qualquer coisa
tem duas grandes variáveis número
variável atrito que o atrito é tudo o
que está emperrando o negócio acontecer
está travando um atrito e outra variável
duas alavancas é tudo que potencializa
tudo que se você dá lhe o bagulho
alavanca tão reduzir o atrito e
potencializar as alavancas tão tão dar
um exemplo escolas nas escolas mudarem
as suas alavancas alavanca pode ser
qualquer programa inovador para formar
professora gestor é a alavanca massa uma
consultoria para transformar as escolas
é alavanca é a família pode ser a
alavanca uma tecnologia uma lei né
atrito com a escola
quais são os atritos para as escolas
mudarem o atrito o mec acaba sendo
atrito apesar de ter evoluído continua
sendo atrito os profissionais do setor
sofre também como secretário de educação
a diretora
o coordenador professor muitas vezes
esse povo já tão tão é engessado pelo
sistema já que já perdeu a fé quando
perde a fé danado quando pegássemos um
amigo é difícil o cara nem mais acredita
no trabalho dele
aí ele viu atrito mas tem um atrito com
a escola mudar é o que eu queria focar a
conversa hoje que é o atrito família
o atrito família é o atrito pouco falado
é muito relevante e à relação escola
família é uma relação cliente fornecedor
do fornecedor família cliente que paga a
mensalidade paga imposto ea escola o
fornecedor que traga o serviço ao
cliente e fornecedor
a lógica qual é é que o fornecedor tem
que ouvir a necessidade do at
o problema é que muitas vezes o cliente
dessa relação à família não tá ligado
que a humanidade está complexa não está
ligado que a necessidade de seres
humanos mudaram e muitas vezes
ae
tá achando que precisa-se de seres
humanos decorador de informação
repertório padrão seguidor de mais nada
porque está ancorado no passado e como
ele foi educado na escola em casa o
educação que antigamente era muito
baseada em obediência higidez disciplina
linearidade equação medo gabarita
decorar passar no vestibular
a pergunta é que estamos precisando
criar vestibulandos ou precisando criar
os futuros adultos da humanidade que
estamos fazendo
e aí essa relação escola família é
difícil porque para o fornecedor fazer
grandes mudanças sem o cliente valorizar
as mudanças
esse é um grande dificultador otegi
toque mais famoso do mundo chama escolas
matam a criatividade que robinson eu
criei o pedex chamado escolas matam
aprendizagem que a pessoa nasce beleza
as escolas antigas matam a criatividade
mata aprendizagem e que marca as escolas
não acredito que muitas vezes os pais
mato às escolas é louco isso né e claro
que se generalizando generalizando
porque os pais variam no espectro que
vai de extrema influência para a escola
não evoluir da família que parte da vida
escolar participa vai participar
trabalhando participar criando atrito
qualquer iniciativa que a evolução já
fica ali travando bagulho tumulto no
grupo do sap tumulto na reunião de pais
e mestres
acho que a reunião de condomínio a ficar
tumultuado a ele vira atrito é louca
cheia de atritos porque as pessoas
quando pensa 30 alavanca elas foco muito
nas alavancas até mesmo uma empresa é
crescer a empresa aí pensa nas alavancas
no marketing muitas vezes velho num
processo de mudança só em reduzir o
atrito negócio já muda muitas vezes a
empresa do universo ele só se ela 30
você não tá vendo que só terá esse
atrito negociados para então existe esse
espectro o extremo do espectro da
família que influencia para não evoluir
o outro extremo é a família que
influencia para evoluir
silva da escola ajudando as iniciativas
que envolva evoluir
nunca dizer que concorda em tudo não tem
que concordar em tudo
quer dizer que família escola concordam
em uma coisa é a necessidade de seres
humanos da humanidade mudou e que nada
do que foi será de novo ct foi o dia que
por essa música boa nota e vida essa
moça é esse espectro não só temos
extremo está você pode como pai na sua
relação com a escola está em qualquer
lugar inclusive votar no meio
o meio é nem atrito e alavanca nem ajuda
atrapalha eu pago e acho que ela está
fazendo
o meio é melhor que o atrito - mal mas
tem que lembrar daquele ditado que para
o triunfo do mal
basta que os bois fiquem de braços
cruzados
é essa questão do espectro
acho que o grande desafio a grande
pergunta é como evoluir então né
seja onde você tiver como sair de
reduzir o atrito e pra vir a alavanca é
como evoluir nesse processo como passar
a ficar alinhado com a escola só para te
ver rápido que família escola alinhado é
massa mas alinhado é uma palavra que eu
não gosto muito que alinhada muita bola
é muito área industrial é muito linda
muito linear
então acho que a família escola tem que
estar sintonizado e sintonizados ou
vários pontos de sintonia fina mas se é
mais complexo né
então vamos lá como evoluir como família
evoluir dessa relação né
então vamos analisar processo de mudança
só que agora em vez de pensar nas
escolas vão pensar no objeto da minha
idéia que hoje que é o que eu quero
falar é sobre família então processo de
mudança da família para alavancar
alavanca podia ser programa de formação
de paz devia ter certificação de pai nem
faz o elenco vai fazer e aí vai planejar
para estar habilitado para tirar sua sua
cnh para dirigir uma criança calma
tentar torná lo
o dia ter atrito
aí o atrito pra família mudar é o cerne
da questão velho é o cerne existe um
grande atrito que atrapalha as famílias
a mudar sua forma de educar as crianças
a evoluir sabe que esse atrito
chama-se ego sabe por quê
porque é muito difícil o pai ou a mãe
tem que assumir que pode não está
educando seu filho do jeito mais
estratégico adequado sintonizado com o
contexto da complexidade é muito
doloroso aceitar isso dói muito ego fica
doido não que história é essa
vai que após saber do carro seis filhos
a fazer o ego ver com a conversa a você
o ego ele é bom de conversa o ego é
ninja só porque é bom de conversa porque
a rede é bom enrolar que a gente conhece
a rede conhece muito bem a gente mesmo
então é bom uma loja que mesmo o ego é
muito sedutor se o ego fosse abalada da
ue como um todo mundo ego a conversa lei
vai aqui e ali web é [ __ ] o ego e ninja
e aí a gente precisa para enfrentar o
ego a sua ignorância é o só sei que nada
sei
assumir que ignora porque a sua
ignorância é liberar espaço no hd para
poder entrar novos arquivos de
atualização é quem tem certeza de mais
nobre espaço aprender milou dizia quem
não tem dúvida que da mãe formato
pessoal fala assim na sua mãe na sua
criança na sua mãe sim na sua mãe mas
não quer dizer que nossa educador não só
porque a educação é um processo dinâmico
ele varia de acordo com as necessidades
da humanidade naquele momento da
educação então você sempre aprendendo a
educar e aí o instinto é lindo mas ele
precisa instrumento perguntar por
exemplo quantas horas pensa quantas
horas já de cássia a estudar buscar
conhecimento o teu trabalho pra tua
profissão
aí as obras da faculdade de sair todos
os livros todos os cursos tudo que você
fez
agora pensa em quantas horas você já se
dedicou ao trabalho mais importante da
sua vida que é educar seres humanos
quantas horas pensa você já o colocou
para estudar sobre isso é a sua
principal contribuição para a humanidade
essa é então tempo eu sei que surge
agora a dor de armas e não tenho tempo
mais uma coisa meu deus tempo é uma
questão de prioridade
se você não tem tempo uma coisa é porque
aqui não está sendo considerado real
prioridade pra você e aí só abre um
parêntese também porque a essa altura
pode emergir um sentimento de culpa e
culpa velho culpa é um negócio que dói
quando envolve filho culpa dói profundo
eu queria convidar você gostar com esse
sentimento a trocar esse sentimento
renomear ele a gratidão gratidão que
está refletindo sobre isso agora e
esquece o passado foco no presente o
foco no próximo passo
fecha parênteses é isso bem então agora
sob olhar é a variável mais importante
pra educar seres humanos e ela precisa
recapitulando primeiro aceitar sua
ignorância
segundo buscar conhecimento terceiro se
abrir à mudança porque vai ter mudança e
4 influenciar os outros influenciar o
sotaque a aceitar a ignorância buscar
conhecimento e se abrir à mudança porque
vai ter influenciar os outros aqui a
aceitar a ignorância buscar conhecimento
e se abrir às mudanças que vai ter
influenciar os outros até já sabem é eu
acho que pai e mãe têm que ser o
metamorfose ambulante e não tem aquela
velha opinião formada sobre tudo
música boa potência também aí é e pai e
mãe precisa ajudar pra criar um novo
jeito de educar seres humanos que vai
ser com certeza diferente do jeito que
você foi a do cabo no passado e
provavelmente diferente do jeito que
você é do campo agora no presente
é esse que eu acho que é o maior déficit
a bairro lacuna a maior oportunidade que
existe no universo da educação é a
educação para tal valeu obrigado a loja
falou
[Aplausos]